welcome to the 24th ever iced coffee
hour podcast
we've made approximately ten thousand
five hundred dollars
welcome well done well done
and by the way if anyone's curious yes
that there's only a 200
jump in the amount of money we've been
made between this podcast episode and
the last one
that is because we're on our grind and
we filmed yesterday
and today back to back because we've
never done that before no we have not
but i'm excited to talk to you
because uh as you guys know moving to
las vegas
you are like the real estate guy in las
vegas
and watching your videos i i've been out
there for a while born and raised man so
done a lot of things out there so i
found you originally on tick tock this
is how this started by the way
so you bought my youtube creator academy
program right and just by pure
coincidence
i found your tick tock video because i
did like a reacting to tick tock
and your video came up of you in
uh sharing this story about how you buy
real estate in las vegas and then i
said the community across the street uh
what did i say it looked like an office
building
yeah and then those gates wouldn't
protect you from a zombie apocalypse
and then we started talking back and
forth and then that turned into me then
asking you advice
uh in terms of moving to las vegas in
the real estate market there
and then your youtube channel too has
been growing a lot lately
yeah it's been exciting man so how did
you get into real estate where did this
start
oh man well before i do that first off
thanks for putting out that uh
creator academy because i would not have
started youtube if i didn't go through
it
and you know i i honestly never thought
anything of youtube because you know
i've been in the business world the
whole time just flipping houses and
stuff and
you know i saw your youtubes during you
know the pandemic and i'm like
dang it's like that these guys are
killing it on youtube i need to get on
that
and the funny thing was you don't even
really promote the the course at all
no and i just happened to be like
looking through the buy and i'm like
wait a minute he's got a course on how
he does it i'm like this is great
and so you know i bought it and started
making youtubes
recently so yeah that's my new career
being a youtuber but um
but yeah prior to that so you're
flipping real estate your real estate
agent too
how many homes have you sold so far how
many homes have you flipped how many do
you own that you just rent out let's get
some quick stats here
yeah so i started real estate in 2010 as
an agent i was 21 years old
and i was just a terrible agent dude i
didn't put in the work at all
um i didn't want to show rentals like
you did
i didn't want to do any of that and so
after a couple years i quit
and you know i did other side hustles
and stuff
i had a good youtube video about
flipping couches and
you know just doing anything to make
money um
but it wasn't until i was 25 so i was
back in 2015 that i
first you know really got into investing
and so
i actually maxed out all my credit cards
back in
2015 and just bought my first flip
and i only had 10 000 um
maxed out 50 grand worth of credit cards
so i could just get the down payment
how do you how do you pay for a house
with a credit card though
because i got a hard money loan on the
flip so they didn't really care
about dti or job income or anything it
was just more so about the deal
and so i found a really good deal um
you know use the credit card money as a
down payment just did a
balance transfer for cash and then
i mean the rest is history started
flipping after that luckily it went
successful
uh made 25 grand on that first one and
then just kept rolling the money over
and over again and
at this point i think i'm close to 400
flips
and what got you interested in the first
flip that you did what gave you the idea
of doing it
ironically it was you know the scammy
infomercials
um i never went to any of the seminars
or anything but i saw them all the time
and i'm like
what are these guys talking about with
you know anyone can flip and you could
flip with no money and i didn't like i
didn't go to the seminar because i knew
i'm like they're just gonna try and
sell me something but i started
researching online and i went to bigger
pockets that's the first time i'd ever
heard about it
and i started listening to their podcast
and all that and
eventually i was like oh these guys are
just either wholesaling
or they're you know just getting hard
money loans to buy this because
i came from the realtor world where it's
like you need to get a 30-year loan
you need perfect dti good credit all
this stuff and i didn't have any of that
so when you say 400 is that including
wholesale deals like how many of those
are wholesale and how many of those you
actually took title to fixed up yourself
and flipped
so i flipped probably from 15
to 2018 95
and that was about 200
homes up to 2018 and then i made the
shift in 2019 i said you know what
we're not gonna just flip every home
that comes through it actually makes
more sense to wholesale
some of these homes um not only to limit
our risk but
i mean there would be times where
somebody would pay us a
20 30 000 wholesale fee and the flip
would only make
30 or 40 and we're like why would we
flip this somebody's
gonna pay us this right now so we made
the switch and started wholesaling
um in 2019 and flipping but i would say
we still flip
70 to 75 percent of them and when you
say we is that
you and and do your partners on this or
how does that work
no so on my flipping business that's all
me i own it 100
um i've got other companies like my real
estate brokerage i have a partner there
um but on the house slipping it was just
me from the ground up just
figuring it out as i went along and then
eventually
realizing hey i need more employees i
need more people to help me out and
you know it just scaled from there man
and we just kept hiring and
building so then what made you want to
do tick tock and
youtube you started tick tock first yeah
why
well i started them at the same time
actually i just hadn't posted on youtube
so during the pandemic like everyone
else i looked at i'm like
ma'am what's gonna happen here like is
vegas about to get crushed because
that's what everyone was saying and
i was like what's like the big play here
should i keep flipping houses if i can't
flip houses
what then you know and some many people
over the years kept telling me you know
go on youtube go on tick tock like these
are you hear gary v talk about it all
the time right
and i always ignored it and i'd always
made content it was on instagram you
know i'd make
five minute videos just me and the
camera not edited or anything
but eventually enough people kept
telling me it that i was like hey i need
to
look into this and so i posted on
instagram i said hey who are the top
youtubers
and everybody's like check out graham
stefan
check out me kevin you know check out
these guys and i'm like okay i'm gonna
check out these guys
and then i was looking at it i'm like
you know these guys are crushing it on
youtube
and i was like i think i could do good
on youtube too
and i think i bring a different
perspective of hey i'm coming from like
the business side of things like running
companies and other stuff not like the
the normal investor who's you know
you know solo investors what i would
call it you know we've got probably
i would say over 100 people total
between all my companies
you know between agents contractors
acquisitions agents and other stuff so
it's like i felt like
nobody on youtube was really giving that
perspective of
hey here's how to run a company versus
you know how to invest for yourself
interesting so but what what prompted
that so i know you want to do this but
why what's the what's the deeper
motivation for doing youtube and tick
tock
well i think back during covet like i
said
i saw it as an opportunity that nobody
was really doing um
in my field anyways like tick tock
definitely nobody was doing
you still don't even like to post oh
gosh i gotta i gotta get into it i just
don't i just don't get it yeah i tried
so hard i really tried hard but i'm
gonna get better guys dude you got good
talks i've seen it um but i just saw an
opportunity i'm like nobody's posting on
tik tok like none of these business guys
take it seriously
and so i'm like i'll just do it and i
don't even know how to make tick tocks i
don't know anything about it but
if i have to dance i'll dance if i have
to like no you wouldn't no you see you
dance
i've done a couple dances but they they
get no views
no i didn't do the watch my wife won't
let me dude
but you know i did that on tick tock
that one this shake that laffy taffy
is that is that the one oh it's dude
dude there's so many things
hundred likes graham will do it right
we'll do the walk with 100
the table no i want if this video gets a
million views
i'll do it if it's okay you guys maybe
edit that out because yeah
i'll read it i'll meet it again okay
people are gonna be left wondering what
i said once again
all right okay just me i was wondering
what you said too
you don't it's weird my ears just toned
out for a little bit i don't know what
you just said but don't do that
did you find immediate success on
tick-tock or was it gradual
yeah tick-tock is one of those things
where it's like anyone can go viral so
quick
it's it's crazy dude um so
i've got like 300 000 something
followers in you know five six months
and it just takes a couple of videos
really
that pop off and people you know the one
you saw did really good and that got me
you know probably tens of thousands if
not a hundred thousand followers
because i got that video early on so
i like tick tock and it's led to a lot
of different opportunities
um not necessarily like uh
you know tick-tock i get all this money
from tick-tock like
adsense or anything but it's opened a
lot of doors
um i have multiple people in vegas
who've reached out to me because
they see me on tik-tok and they're like
hey i want to work with you in this type
of way
in different business ventures so it's
been really cool what's the secret to
making a good tick tock i feel like you
would have had it figured out like what
how do you do that i think there's a
couple of things but number one
is you gotta catch the trends just like
youtube but like there's trending sounds
so you gotta use their sounds because
people will you know
watch a certain sound and just see what
everyone did to that sound
so even if you have it not playing and
you have the sound muted
that's a good way to to get traction um
i would say another thing is
you got to hook them in within like two
seconds you know and youtube
maybe you hook them in within 20 30
seconds you got two seconds on tick tock
or they're swiping
um how do you hook what's what's the
strategy to get a good hook there
you can do it either visually
or you know with audio so i mean
visually you would do it by
maybe you're just immediately the first
frame of the bikini
is yeah whatever you know it is what it
is i'll be in a bikini and somebody's
like what's going on here like i need to
watch the rest of this
um but yeah so you could do it visually
or audio
you know you just start you know yelling
something you got to have high energy
you can't just mumble it whatever or you
know you put the text on there like an
instagram story and you know maybe it
says something crazy like
you know this is how i made a million
dollars and then they'd be like whoa
yeah you know follow me to learn more
and i'll never tell you
okay i think you'll watch the next one
how i made two million dollars
follow me but people do that like okay
stay tuned for part two then i'll tell
you but make sure to follow
hey dude i've seen those two and then
you go into their profile
and part two was posted like months ago
and you can't find it
yeah yeah tick tock's not very organized
at all if you want to find the content
good luck
geez gosh okay so you got to have an
immediate hook but what type of content
does the best there
i think they're all very it doesn't
matter i mean finance and
real estate aren't going to do that
great i mean it's dancing and
you know very like prank stuff but that
kind of content
but the beauty is there's not many
finance people on it you know a lot of
people watching this
you probably are into finance so it's a
good opportunity because it's such low
competition
you know um but i would just say
you could literally do anything on tick
tock there's and
with like the uh cpm it's the same no
matter what you do
so it doesn't matter hmm how much do you
get paid on tick tock
i saw your video i saw your video on it
but i'd like you to show us
could you can you whip out the phone
let's see let's take a look i want to
see how many views you're getting
okay and then how much you're making
from that
all right so we've got 325 000 followers
okay so look dude i made 20 bucks today
that's actually
really good 20 today i mean 34 i don't
know wow
oh you know what happened i made a
really good video with my wife
it was her birthday and i took her on a
shopping spree
and so people were really hooked on it
but i've made 452 dollars on
like lifetime 452 dollars
lifetime with three no i have to apply
get funding to make content apply
and is there different cpms for
different types of content no it's the
same it's it's three
cents three cents per thousand views
three cents per thousand
it's crazy i i get a thousand times
better
on youtube yeah a thousand a thousand
times better
so one view on youtube is is the
equivalent it's a thousand times more
valuable
wow that's incredible
oh jack i forgot i wanted to tell you
this because i watched your interview
with andre but
um i should have started out with this
but i want you to know you're a
good-looking guy dude oh you stop it
oh you are gorgeous are you kidding me
i was gonna comment but it would have
got flooded so i had to tell you in
person you are gorgeous man
thank you so much it is too sweet
all right i'll do that later i'm going
to apply now you can start making money
you'll make probably five bucks that'd
be good piece for sushi
i mean that's the thing for an entire
week that's a free sushi meal
every single week paid for by tik tok
that's true yeah
now what about you just gotta produce
more content that's it i know
what would what would be your
recommendation to me if i
if i wanted to grow on tick tock what
should i do
well for you it'd be easy because you
already have such a massive following
that if you just post
everyone from youtube is going to go
watch it i mean that's how i feel
you know um but if i was you i'd keep
doing the videos you were doing they
were good
yeah just quick short form five best
investments what i'm investing in this
week
very raw don't you know put too much
effort like seriously this is my routine
i try and post two a day that's my goal
two a day two
wow so i'll post two a day i'll film
them in the morning
so if you watch my tick tocks a lot i'm
in my gym clothes because i'm just
filming them before the gym takes me
like 30 minutes i'm just trying to bust
out
whatever i can think of so that's what i
would do
what do you talk about whatever i feel
like so
i'll talk about um real estate some type
of
tip with real estate whether it be
investing house flipping whatever
um i'll also talk about current events
you know with related to finance
whatever i think that'd be
great for you because you love talking
about this stuff anyway
i would take anything you talk about on
youtube and just make it a tick tock
because you've already did it um i was
talking about logan paul and his pokemon
the other day you know because
some people were talking about so i
think you literally can just take
whatever you're doing on youtube and
just make a 15 to 30 second clip of it i
think it would be fairly easy for you to
be successful and take talk definitely
because i feel like transferring from
youtube to tick tock i think you've said
this before it would be
way easier than tick tock to youtube but
you're lazy so successful at that man
yeah it's it's been crazy i don't know i
feel like your youtube growth is youtube
your tick tock growth is tick tock
your youtube has been doing really well
because you're doing well at youtube
i would say you're like 75 right
i think tick tock has definitely played
a role because
i i do and tick tocks push them to
youtube you know that's the call to
action at the end hey
for instance your video that we're
talking about it's like 30 seconds right
you're like hey if you want the full
video on this
go watch it on youtube because i can
only tell you so much in 30 seconds
and that's how you can push them to
youtube so
i think it's definitely helped but i
agree i mean i think they are two
totally different audiences for sure
um they have very low attention spans on
tick tock
you know what i'll try i'll redo that
video that how much i make with two
million subscribers i'll put that on
tick tock
i guarantee you'll get millions really
sure do you think so how much do you
make with
yeah 100 yeah really okay let's let's
try it you know what
i'll put it up tomorrow it'll be my
promise to you okay and then we'll
reevaluate a week from now and we'll see
how it does and then what i'll do is
i'll do edit and then i'm going to take
credit i'm going to say
i told graham to do this video so you
guys need to follow me
all right let's do it let's try that hey
guys i'm just going to throw this in
really quickly graham posted the video
and it went viral
overnight and it has over 10 million
views and over like a million likes
so i'll throw up screenshots right over
this um let's talk
because i i'm actually really excited
about talking about this is investing in
real estate in las vegas yeah because
it's brand new
jack's really excited i'm so excited has
been talking gamble too right yeah
yes jack's been talking no joke for two
weeks
about how excited he's been to talk to
you tonight
about investing in real estate because
jack wants to invest
in las vegas i cannot do it here i mean
i don't have like a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to put down i mean i
probably will more than you will
but still like i could afford a down
payment on a place in las vegas
but i mean you can just get an fha loan
you know yeah but i wouldn't
live there wouldn't i need to live there
yeah yeah i'm not gonna do that
okay i gotta you gotta yeah jack is uh
mooching
right here we didn't have it any other
way
i don't know i don't blame you yeah
jack's the kid he won't move out
i won't no i want him to go off on his
own one day and he's like i'm like a
barnacle dad the meatloaf
dad where's the meatloaf do you cook
jack
i do yeah and i peanut butter and jelly
dude
came down and he came down and we could
work on something together
and i had a plate with two peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches and he looked at me
with this face of disgusting
i hate jack so well jack what so well
what other value do you understand other
than being an awesome
good-looking podcast host um with a very
symmetrical face very symmetrical
face i i was gonna say it but i just
figured it it's perfectly symmetrical
absolutely for those that don't get the
joke watch
the end of the andre it is i'm not even
kidding though when i say that like you
draw a line in your face and it
and it's just even on both sides like
the top you can fold it and it'd just be
yeah just exactly but yeah i mean i
bring i bring a
value because i edit for the second
channel okay um
you know graham and i we produce
something like a mastermind when we're
together
we've i'm just not a mastermind but we
bounce ideas yeah we talk about what we
do
good titles and thumbnails we're both
very different independent thinkers
okay i think that we work well together
and of course there are other things
that i do like uh
emails an indian mentorship group jack
runs that
uh ideas emails some ideas some
sometimes sometimes
random work um reaching out to people on
my behalf so yeah it works well it's
just a bunch of randomness i should have
brought my jack
i i recently hired a jack yeah how's
that working out for you
he's great he's just like you he's
really young he's 20 years old
you know and he's just great he he sent
me the best
like interview video i've ever seen i'll
show you guys it after
okay like i i was like i gotta hire this
guy i don't even have a position for him
but he's
he's great it's good yeah that's awesome
so what is your advice to jack to invest
in las vegas
actually how about this give us a
rundown first of like what the market is
like in las vegas because
andre and i you so i know you saw that
part we had a bit of a back and forth
i'm saying the market's going up but
he's saying it's going down
who's right i would i would i'll leave
it to you to be that tie breaker i would
i would trust your judgment on this one
well i think obviously because andre's
still trying to buy his first house yeah
so it's like i get it he's very nervous
about it
i totally like first-time homebuyers get
that all the time
but my thing with vegas is there's no
inventory like the only way it crashes
if
is if there's this sudden rush of
inventory which
to me is not going to happen at least in
the next six months
not with all the the legal stuff going
on not with
you know foreclosures being halted and
all this so i don't see anything
happening on that front
and then you gotta assume all these
people like you who are moving in
are kind of combating that so it's like
i don't think it's going anywhere and in
fact
if i had to guess it probably will go up
what about andre had some good points
about
the job market in las vegas and a lot of
people being laid off
right the unemployment can't go on
forever right
um what is what are your thoughts on
that because i do agree with them in the
sense that
if you have let's say 15 of the
population just
unemployed right now that's that that
has to have some residual effect on the
market
i mean here's what i think is gonna
happen um
[Music]
and it's i've been saying this since
probably
may so let me backtrack and say back in
when you know everything happened all my
friends stopped buying
all my flipper buddies investors they
all just were like
we're running for the hills we saw what
happened to vegas last time and i was
like dude i'm gonna keep buying like
i see a lot of things that i think are
gonna be okay and it turned out to be
right
and you know i bought some super good
deals because
there was no competition no one was
buying and
i mean we're still buying five to ten a
month so like i'm super confident
at least in the short term but the
reason i'm confident is number one
there's low supply
so it's still gonna take a while before
supply increases
even if this happens it will take a
while but the other thing is
i think the banks are going to work with
them i think
all these people in mortgage forbearance
are not going to get foreclosed on
12 months after the fact they're going
to get loan mods and i think
even if they don't have a job the bank
is going to find a way to work with them
and so that's why i don't see this flood
of inventory the other problem is
the people who would sell otherwise are
not selling because of this
because they're in forbearance and so if
they try and sell now even with equity
they have nowhere to go because they
don't have a job they can't qualify for
another house
so their only option is to keep their
home or rent
they can't rent though they don't have a
job but they would have money from
selling a house if they have equity
right if somebody's gonna take them with
no job right so it's like
to me the best choice for everyone is
always to just
work with the bank and i think that's
what most people are gonna do
and i think the banks are going to work
with them because they're going to get
incentivized yeah
so you think the market is going to stay
at worst steady
and realistically it's probably going to
go up continue going up
for sure and i think when i'm saying
this i'm just talking the short term
six to 12 months i mean in the long term
real estate will always be a good
investment it doesn't matter where you
buy
but in the short term as like a flipper
who's trying to make a profit here in
the next three to six months
i'm very confident so what markets are
you investing in like what price point
what do you go for what's the cash flow
like
in vegas yeah so in vegas
i don't have a ton of rentals i probably
have
i have a 10 unit apartment and then
probably like six
or seven single families uh that's not
it that seems like a ton to me man oh my
god but when you do yeah when you
compare it to you know flipping 100
homes
we don't keep a lot of them and the
reason i don't keep a lot of them
i would love to it's just the vegas cash
flow isn't very good
i mean at the end of the day if
you got to look at every home you buy in
the lens of what's the best exit
strategy and so every time we get a home
we'll say hey
okay i got this home what what can i do
i can wholesale it for
20 grand right i can flip it and make 40
grand
or i can keep it as a rental and if i
use the bur
strategy even if i use that i might cash
flow 100 bucks a month 200 bucks a month
because you got to remember we're not
putting a significant down payment you
know we're trying to get all of our cash
back and get the highest leverage
when we keep rentals so it never really
pencils out to keep it in vegas
that's the problem what rois are you
seeing though let's say i went in there
with uh
like 500 grand cash like i just want to
make
a decent return nothing phenomenal i
just want to get a nice respectable
return
and a good area what would you recommend
and what would the cash flow be like
just
on the average place nothing spectacular
just are you going to leverage the 500
just buy cash we could go both options
let's say i buy cash i want to see what
the what the total return is
i mean let's just say you buy it in a
nice um
you know middle class area newer home
you know maybe you're spending 300 to
350
and that house is going to rent for like
2 200 bucks
that's d i mean it's better than l.a so
i see everything from the perspective of
like l.a that's dc that's pretty good
yeah so now i'm going to vegas being
like wow this is phenomenal i could do
this
better yeah yeah that's how i see it but
when you look at
other markets the cash flow is
much better you know and i'm not even
talking the midwest where everything is
just
stupid cheap and like the returns on
paper look good but they're
not at the end of the day yep um but
like so we invest in tucson as well
and i don't have any rentals in tucson
but we've done flips out there
but like tucson you could get and i hope
this doesn't
oh yeah over saturday just tucson wait
wait no this is just about to click off
you wouldn't mind i thought you were
you're saying that because you're
approaching 30 minutes
oh no yeah so in tucson
you could get a house for say 150 to 200
it'll rent for 1500 bucks or more so
you're like almost hitting the one
percent rule
in like a major market that is that's a
college town that you know has a lot
going on
so that's why i kind of looked there if
i wanted to get some single families
[Music]
so it sounds like renting like our just
having uh
rentals isn't the greatest investment in
las vegas
would you still say it's it's a viable
option for me if i could find a good
place
in vegas or you think that it's just
probably not worth
my time or i think it it depends on your
opportunity cost so i think like
for a lot of people if they're just
gonna buy one home
yeah buying the vegas home is better
than buying the home out here
your return will be better but when
you're
for me like let's just say i was gonna
put 20 down on this home okay i put 60
grand down on a 300 000
house i can get a way better return with
my 60 grand because
we come across deals all the time you
know and i can use that to flip
and make a lot more money so that's kind
of just like
my pers like my perspective so it really
depends on
what your opportunities are in front of
you
sounds good to me yeah i'm just i'm just
so eager
that's my idea i'll try and i'm getting
a little like
too complex your buy your first deal buy
my first deal just buy it
that's that's what i want to do but i'm
also scared that i'm getting like
overzealous i think that i'm gonna
i don't know i'm naive because i haven't
the biggest thing i see is
the analysis paralysis it's like so many
people
do not pull the trigger because they're
like so consumed with analyzing
talking like they talk themselves out of
many deals right you could have bought
the worst deal ever five years ago
and you're looking smart you're looking
like a genius and so
if you buy a deal today i can guarantee
you five years from now
it will have been a good decision but
i'd also need to like familiarize myself
with the market and stuff like that
to find a deal yeah well it just depends
what kind of deal you're trying to find
like if you're only looking in a certain
pocket
of las vegas yeah it could be difficult
but if you're open to any and everything
and you're just looking for equity
i mean there's tons of deals out there
it just is a matter of are you okay
buying in that area
or that house what about appreciation
because you're talking about some of
these areas you get really good cash
flow i don't know if they'll see the
appreciation that las vegas might see in
some of these areas
right right i think it you know i've
seen the zip code appreciation maps
um over the years and it's always hit or
miss
because sometimes you'll get an area
like summerlin
that on paper doesn't appreciate a lot
um
and then you'll see like these really
you know distraught areas have
huge appreciation but the reason that it
has the huge appreciation
is because that's where all the flippers
are the flippers are buying them for 100
000 and selling them for 200 000
but they can't take into account that
well they put 50 000 into it and
you know that's the reason they forced
appreciation it's not like it naturally
happened
so when you look at those maps it's hard
to say oh man like this is the area to
invest in it had the most because
if you look most of the bad areas
appreciate the most
so it's really hard to say which is best
but for me as an investor i always if i
can force appreciation that's what i
want to do
so they're going into these areas people
are still paying those those prices but
because there's now like 70 grand
extra in these homes so people are
willing to pay for that
i mean makes sense to me yeah for sure
okay yeah
so what are your thoughts in on like
summerlin henderson
those areas between the two you gave me
some really good advice we talked on the
phone
you have to remind me which advice it
was oh just the differences between
summerlin and
henderson oh okay um so i love both
summerlin and henderson i mean
they're the premier areas of vegas um
i would guess most people from cali
looking you know in that million plus
range are gonna end up in one of those
two
um i like summerlin
i like them both for long term i don't
see one or the other just
you know outperforming each other it
really is going to depend on
the lifestyle you want to live and so
like henderson
if i was telling you this you got really
good
views if you're willing to pay for it
you can't touch the views in henderson
they're the best
um summerlin though to me has a lot more
nicer homes
in that like price point you bought in
for sure we were looking at them like
you know yeah these summerlin homes are
better at this price point
but i think once you get to an even
higher price point then it's like i
would go with henderson for sure
um but if like you're in jack's
situation and you're buying
let's just say this three that 300 000
400 000
home i would pick summerlin for sure
because they got really nice communities
at that price point
see buy a home over there and then you
can leave graham's home
find a place on my own i'll have to uh
do his own grocery shopping
i already do that if anyone's wondering
i already do my own groceries
do you guys do your own laundry
i look so bad i look so
honestly well that's really insightful
thanks so much yeah
i'm gonna have so many other random
questions in las vegas i just don't know
like
hit me with the random ones i talked
about
i grew up in south las vegas so i was
born and raised in vegas and then i
actually
went to college here at csun so pretty
close to here
and um played baseball there and got
drafted by the oakland a's
what yeah are you serious yeah so
did that for three years with the a's
and then i played another five years
professionally on um
it's called independent baseball still
pro baseball but um
and dude i've played all over the
country and
yeah i didn't even talk about that but
that was how my investing career started
i would play baseball six months out of
the year
and then i would invest six months out
of the year
that is so cool that what position did
you play
second base i love baseball yeah i love
being here's your team
dodgers okay i mean i i paid most
attention to baseball it was years ago
it was the team like raphael for call
james lonely oh yeah matt kemp one
pierre like that whole
loney lives in vegas does he really yeah
yeah you're gonna get to meet him dude
i'll make an introduction that is wow
oh we should we should get his crazy i
mean i loved that team that was my that
was my dodgers team 100
and that's so cool you played second
base yeah can we talk about like
salaries and stuff in baseball oh dude
i'm happy so
it's funny man because people are like
dude you must have been getting paid
like especially on tick tock they'll be
like well yeah it's easy to start
investing when you know you played pro
baseball and i'm like dude you have no
idea
so i was a late round draft pick i
signed for twenty thousand dollars which
you know it's a 21 year old it's not
insignificant
but it's not the millions that these
first rounders get you know the ones
you're reacting to
oh yeah second channel yeah two uh
to a 40 million dollar contract yeah
like four years it ain't like that so i
got 20
dollars out of college and i thought i
was gonna get a lot more but
it is what it is right and
during the seasons you only get paid
1200
a month so i was making 1200 i'm not
kidding 1200 a month we we've done the
minimum wage it was like three dollars
an hour
and you only get that while you're
playing so
the season's only six months so i was
making 7 200
a year in minor league baseball
and so that was why i became a realtor
because i mean i can't live off 7 200
so i had to get a second job and i
needed something that
you know i could actually leave and come
back and do
but the problem was i was never good at
being a realtor
because you know i'd be playing baseball
i wasn't really focused on it and i
hated it too
but dude it's crazy like
how much how little money they pay you
in the minor leagues
i totally thought it would have been way
more than that considering that the jump
between that and the majors is like
crazy is it going from a psa 9 to a 10.
it is that's what it is that little
difference
yeah isn't it yeah mlb don't they have
like a minimum is it like four million
yeah it's like half a mil is the minimum
wow yeah
and even in like triple a you know
people so i was only in single a
but like in triple a if you're not part
of the 40 man roster what they call it
it's still like 2 000 a month it's not
anything
and even when you make the 40 man roster
which means you're
you might be getting close to the big
leagues um
the first year i want to say they were
they make like 40 000 a year like it's a
significant jump from
what you were making but still it's it's
40 000 a year what about like managers
do they take
is there like a like an agent or
something or how does that work
yeah so i had an agent and they take a
portion of your signing bonus
i don't even remember mine was so small
it was like four percent or something
um but in the in the minor leagues
they're legally not allowed to take any
of that because you'll
you know you'll starve and um yeah
once you sign your first big league
contract then they start taking that
you know three to five percent again
what do they do
not much man um
i should i shouldn't take that i should
take that back but they
they'll negotiate the contract right i
mean cool most athletes don't have any
business savvy right
so okay you need them to negotiate that
contract but from there
until you sign that next contract which
in baseball is
way down the road you know your signing
bonus that first one
say you're 18 years old out of college
or out of high school i mean you may not
get your first real contract until
you're
25 you know it's seven years of them
not really doing anything other than hey
you know how's it going ryan
just checking in on you you need any
cleats or something like they'll send
you equipment
wow that's pretty much it what what
happened what
why didn't you progress further was it a
choice of yours or was it just
didn't happen i just think i didn't have
the talent level man
um once i mean
you start reaching every level like
and seeing how good these guys are so
like in high school right
for most part most people like they'll
either fall off or you know there'll be
that stud right who maybe gets to
college
and then you play college baseball and
like i played out here right
and you start to see all these people
across the country like dane these guys
are good
like these were the best of the best of
their high schools
and then from there they get drafted and
you're like these were the best of the
best
not only in college but also now high
school but also now
across the entire world because now
you're getting all the dominicans
the asians whatever like they're
everyone's coming together now
to compete across the world you're like
holy smokes like
now all these guys are
monsters i i went from i'm 510 i'm like
not a big guy by any means but
i went from being like a power hitter in
college
to i'm the smallest guy on my team
seriously yeah
and so for like a guy like me who's
very small as an athlete uh normal size
as a businessman
but um it was just like wow these guys
are good and it's not like i was
intimidated it was just like yo if i
want to succeed
i got a physiological barrier that's why
i gotta go above
that's why i was never a pro uh
basketball player
well what's interesting is like so i
never played football
i thought about being a linebacker
genetics you're like nope you can't you
can't do that you got to make youtube
videos
you got a great youtube personality
jeez yeah i'm not good at sports i i
never not at all no no what did you play
nothing you never played anything no
you'd be good at
rock climbing like bouldering don't you
think so okay
yeah yeah did you play square how did
you how do you play that again what was
that it sounds familiar
okay you didn't play what about
tetherball tyler ball's incredible uh
no tetherball you got to be really tall
to get that like as it goes up time no
you gotta have good hops
just jump yeah no no no no because the
thing is
when the ball is all the way unravel
like that thing goes high yeah
i can't i can't grab that you so you
don't what about running
or something as much i was i was
physically bad
at any sport in p.e oh my god
you're pretty fit though yeah but that's
from like weights that's right you're
not right so you work out
yeah i do you like lifting yeah but a
lot of it is just aesthetics like
physically i'm still pretty weak but
it's for a long time
say that but it's just for looks but you
know i would rather
i would rather look good than actually
like be strong and not like you know
those big bulky guys that are super
strong
it's not practical at all um like like
yeah i like working out
uh but then when it comes time to move a
couch like i'm sitting there be like i
can't move
we're gonna have to hire someone what is
this is heavy yeah you are pretty good
though like
we do pull-ups and graham's like like
that like he's going fast so you have a
good
like strength to muscle yeah but uh
strength to weight ratio yeah he's
strong
yeah yeah in school though i was always
like the last one to be picked
for like sports like throughout like i
don't
i mean the truth is that who's laughing
now yeah yeah
well still but i don't know if we could
put this on the podcast but but the
truth
you decide but but the truth is that
there was me maybe don't put that in
there
just just because maybe don't put that
but either way
but that's how that's what it was that's
usually what it what it was
wow yeah but i was also but i also had
asthma
so like on top of everything else and
it's like i i don't
like running you didn't like did you not
like any sport no
no no enjoyment maybe it was just
because you had such bad experiences
never got into even watching sports like
i just don't i don't understand i don't
get it
i don't know you enjoy sports correct
like obviously oh i love it
you know what i think it's i don't do
well with uh like team sports i like to
just do something on my own are you are
you competitive
uh not really well a little bit
yeah i'm more competitive with my with
myself with your job and you're
competitive
yeah do you want to be like the best the
best youtuber
um yeah yeah no yes yes and no
i mean there were certainly milestones
where it was it was an accomplishment
for me to be like
i looked up to dave ramsey's channel
right and so to to one day
have more subscribers and that was a
huge accomplishment for me because like
oh wow like i
i was watching dave ramsey's channel
from the very beginning i always aspire
to be like
one day if i could do that like that
would be a big deal so those little
milestones for me were really
significant
right because i just know for me like
obviously most athletes are
just hyper competitive and so i've taken
that into everything i do i'm like
all right i want to be the best house
slipper in las vegas you know
how do i do that and then it's like okay
if i do that great what's next
and so that's kind of also where youtube
came into play it was like well we've
been flipping
100 plus houses since 2018. it's like
what
what else is there like do i flip 200 do
i flip 300 like is that what i want to
do
not really like what's another challenge
and
i just saw youtube and so i'm like you
know what
out for me i want to be the best
youtuber that's you know flipping houses
and doing all this stuff in my lane in
my
niche you know because i just don't see
really anyone else doing it
and so it's just another competitive
thing to do and then i think once i do
that i'll be like all right now what's
next
so where would be the point then that
you get to be like okay
i did this what's that like what goals
do you have when it comes to this
i think for me a million subscribers
would be a big milestone
um i looked at it when i started this
year i said
the goal for this year if i could do it
i would be so hyped would be a hundred
thousand subscribers
and you know in sports there's always
numbers like you're just trying to hit
numbers
and you know we'll see what happens you
know if people
subscribe after this great let's pause
it right here so we have more people
watching right now than later
if you haven't already first line of the
description his youtube channel
click on it get it done subscribe get
him as many subscribers
and you gotta subscribe to this channel
because here's the weird thing we've
been getting so far like almost a
hundred thousand views last few videos
why don't we unsubscribe no one is why
i don't get it why aren't you subscribed
here's an honest comment for you
if you're watching this right now and
you're not subscribed
i just want to know the reason that
you're not going to subscribe
after i ask please please do it it's
worth it
but but if you're not going to if you're
like listen grams like sorry
i like this video i'm not going to just
comment down below because we want to
improve also yeah if you dislike these
videos like if you do the dislike button
let us know why yeah i'm really good who
does that i don't think i've ever
disliked a youtube video no i don't
think i i think i have i
i have a few times it's
rare like even if i dislike the video
like i personally like i don't like it
at all
i won't dislike the video but there's
there's every now and then
you just want to be like listen to me
you disliked okay so
these people made an ad on you and i
noticed you disliked the video
i thought it was funny i would have
liked it so people made an ad with
graham's face on it oh because
graham did an instagram post and he said
if you find the ad
screen record it and upload it to
youtube and tell me about it so someone
did that yeah and then graham clicked on
the link
and it went to a youtube video where
it's just a black screen and it was
playing like the
the oh what is it that um
no no it's um larry david
yeah yeah uh curb curb your enthusiasm
song yeah it was just playing that stuff
we'll play it because it'll get uh
you know what we could play like a brief
second this is it i don't i don't think
i kept
the dislike on there though this isn't
you undisliked
oh yes sir okay that's it graham kept
the dislike
listen when something has 36 likes and
76 dislikes
i mean like it listen i get it it's
clever but
uh but dislike but i disliked it
he disliked the video he wanted to see
the ad unfortunately he didn't you got
to see it later
i got to see it later two other people
uploaded the video thank you so much
for that it was clever listen i i have
nothing against it it's just
it's a dislike it's okay if you dislike
videos let us know why you dislike
videos if you've ever disliked one of
graham's videos one of ryan's videos
let us know most of my dislikes are for
my hair
to be honest what you look like cr7 man
i get that too but i'm like the uh the
super poor man's version of cristiano
but uh on tick-tock they say that like
tick-tock
they those kids are ruthless yeah like
dude they have no filter
so they'll be like you bootleg cristiano
or they'll be like dude
cut that hair off what are you doing
like it's crazy but then on instagram
it's a more mature audience they're like
dude we love your hair
so i don't know it's unique it makes you
stand out which is what you want to do
as a business person
right now i'm stuck with it graham does
yeah it does make you you stand out yeah
you said you would do pink or green hair
like
like uh you see no like zh or ninja
ninja
i think he would do that it is cool i
thought he was joking when he said he
would do that no i think it's cool
i i think if you build a brand around
that like you think ninja you think
colored hair
you think zhc you think that teal color
it's it's their brand
it makes them significantly more
memorable
and i think with you almost with your
hair yeah i don't have the hairline to
do something like that you got the
hairline where you could make
it hairline it is yeah well and the
people always say how long does it take
you to do your hair i'm like it honestly
doesn't take that long
but it does but the thing is cutting it
like how often do you get
i'll get a haircut like once a week once
a week
hair like that i wonder how they cut it
did they just get like something and
like
make a ruler like an inch off the head
and they just
like it just it's just everything is so
perfect
we'll vlog it next time please do i
would i'm so interested how did you how
did you pick the hairstyle
well now that we're into it teach us
yeah because i'm curious
so my hair looks exactly like my dad's
hair
but more like modern so my dad obviously
does not have like
this you know cut part i just noticed
that you have a line
that yes that's that's just that you
yeah so that's the barbershop
you show the camera he's got a line so
um my dad obviously doesn't have the
part he doesn't line up the front or
anything my barber does that but my
dad's hair
is just like this yeah it's like the
bruno mars hair it's filipino hair dude
it's just your filipino yeah
cool so that's just our natural hair it
just poofs up
that is awesome i'm jealous but how did
you pick the style
you went to the barber one day just like
so i was looking at cristiano
and i was like dude that guy he's almost
as good looking as jack he's like oh my
goodness
say no more fam you know
it's a nice hairstyle it is a nice
hairstyle i must say i know but the tick
tockers hate it
but how did you pick it where did this
start i started doing this hairstyle
probably right when i started flipping
houses just knew me dude
i actually shaved my head when i was 21
believe it or not
that was not a good look i thought it
was um and then i had a faux hawk
for a really long time and i even had a
mohawk too
but it was like you know it's not like
your punker mohawk just like one of
those
ones and then one day i just was like
dude you know what i'm going back to
my old hairstyle when i was a kid
because when i was a kid i actually did
my hair like you yeah
the justin bieber yeah i just parted it
over
yeah and i was like oh no back then it
was the zac efron i had his hair cut
before he had his hair cut like i've had
this haircut
since i was like eight or nine no joke
i've had the same haircut this entire
time
well dude and then it became very
popular in uh 2005
2006. it's like it goes out then it
comes back in
and then yeah but yeah i was like you
know what i'm going back to my hairstyle
as a kid so i was like
pulling it over but i realized my hair
was now like poofy
so it was like it evolved over yeah and
i was like
i guess i'll just kind of like do this
in between thing ryan v2
is what you called it that is awesome
dude yeah yeah i'm wearing a hat because
i could not
show myself show my hair like this what
do you mean because i get these things
my mom calls them wings because my hair
so long it hits my ears it shoots out at
the side
well thanks for telling us the uh the
history of the hair it's good it's a
good hairline
people ask a lot so they're going to be
happy do they really ask
yeah what do they say it's like what's
questions
how long does it take what's on your
head you know
have you thought about making it uh tick
tock like like my hair routine like that
yeah i did the truth about my hair
yeah i already did it really yeah how
did it do
pro i don't even know we'd have finding
it on tick tock is so hard
yeah you can't even search for it okay
but it was it was okay
it wasn't viral you know like the people
did like the forehead reveals and stuff
like that on tick tock yeah that was
like a huge thing they would like get
their hands and they'd like move it up
their forehead and pull it back to their
hair
you had to do a forehead reveal i mean
you would you would
ace that test you would ace it
yeah i haven't seen that one speaking
weird things on tick tock there's the
one
that i saw that macy was showing me this
where it's
it's you show the side profile it's like
this
big like big reveal like everyone sees
your face and then you turn to the side
and like the music it's like avril
lavigne playing something in the back
it's it's
the bad one the head on or the side the
side it's supposed to it's supposed to
be like
i look pretty from the front but then
you see the side and then like the
i'll show it to you guys we probably
gotta turn the cameras off and on again
here ryan while we're doing this you
want to do a segment where we uh we go
over your outfit and how much each
article of clothing costs
okay i actually did one of graham's
videos where i talk about how much i
spend a month
and we had a lot of people comment like
dude
graham would not be happy how much do
you spend a month
probably like 20 grand on personal
spending wait what
um for what why dude that's not personal
it's the hair the hair is 15 000 a month
yeah getting his healthcare every
every week no i mean i got a family so i
mean i have two kids
we got a lot of two i didn't know you
had two kids they're both under two so
they're really young
wow yeah so i just did a video on it um
i've never actually budgeted so it was
my first time really looking at it and
seeing like man where are we at
it's about 20 000 a month why
so where does this break down so you got
a family so where's the problem
let's find out where the leak is where
the financial leak is okay so
i know where the leak is okay so you so
you have a so a wife and two kids how
long have you been married
seven years seven years how old are you
i'm 31 dude
are you really yeah so my why did i
think you're i thought you were like 25
or something like that it's because i'm
asian dude it's just we look young wow
you've been blessed yeah seriously if
you told me you're like
24 23 i would have been like yeah yeah
so wow we um we got married really young
she was 21
i was 24. so we actually that's why we
came out here when i told you i was like
we're going out to
newport to celebrate our anniversary for
anniversaries congratulations thank you
it's on sunday wow so seven years cool
but yeah we waited five years and now we
have two kids
and um but yeah on the spending side how
much is the house let's start with the
house
so i said that our house is about 4 000
a month mortgage
but we also support my parents so their
house is like 2 000
and then we have a missionary house
that's about 1 500. so i said it was
like
7 500 bucks sure um utilities
insurance all that stuff was a few
thousand bucks so you're at like
what do you mean that's a lot a few
thousand dollars utilities
well in three houses a few thousand
dollars
yeah i'm saying the electric bill here
between like 850
well so i think i'd have to go back to
the video but i said utilities was
probably fifteen hundred that's 500 a
house
that's at 500 houses a lot
man are utilities that much more in
vegas really dude
you'll have a power bill in the summer
like your new house your power bill will
probably be 500 bucks no it won't
i compared electricity right between la
and vegas and they're about 30
less in vegas electricity and water yeah
but i don't keep it that cold
i would if electricity is going to be
that much i'd be like i know it's going
to be 80 degrees inside
is it warm in here for you no i'm good
see so
80 degrees it's nice well even whatever
it's a thousand bucks for 3
000 i turn on the ac usually like 78
like 78 degrees
yeah that's way too hot no it's not it's
we're chilling at like 72 all the time
um
what else we got so insurance um you pay
450 so that's really cheap actually
that's really cheap yeah um
what else we got we've got car the tesla
out there
1300 bucks um okay i mean it makes sense
to finance that
yeah okay all our other cars are paid
off so no other payments
um i said car insurance was about a
thousand bucks for
everyone's cars um
uh what else we got what are the other
personal expenses uh food okay so food
is where everyone said you'd freak out
so we spend about 150
bucks a day on food between
that's four people right you're two
dollars two babies
two kids 150 a day yeah so they're
eating lobster
soups
a hundred and fifty dollars so that's
forty five hundred
forty five hundred why so much
dude because i ate so like
bad when i was playing minor league
baseball because we would make 1200
bucks a month
and i hated it and so i was actually
super frugal
like i was pinching every penny you
could pinch i was meal prepping
you know bringing food on the road all
this stuff because i had to
and i always remember i was like dude
one day the day i can
not have to worry about my food budget
like i'm rich
i'm good and so once i finally just was
like dude i make enough money
where you know what's four thousand
dollars at the end of the day that's it
i i i consider myself to make a lot i
look at that i'm like four thousand
dollars a month i in fact i've wanted
sushi
this entire week but i'm saving it for i
think saturday night
and then it's like 30 bucks but i'm
saving it for that and no joke i kid you
not i'm looking forward to that
this entire week i can't wait to do that
yeah
that's a big deal that's a big splurge
graham and i are
a little bit different on this i think
that's totally reasonable to spend 4 500
like oh it's a lot it is a lot but
considering your current position
i think food is i mean i understand
where you want to spend
spent like split can i i mean how much
do you make in total
we're 4 500 a month because i don't know
if i'll get to that point where it's
like
i don't i don't make as much as you so
but i make a lot of money as far as
flipping and all this other stuff goes i
mean it's over six figures a month
so over a million dollars a year yeah
congratulations man
thank you so that's significant though
yeah do you ever think you would you'd
be doing this much
i never did no i mean
i thought i'd be doing it but in
baseball and when baseball was over i
was like
i don't know what i'm gonna do wow you
know and
eventually once i started flipping
houses then it became really significant
and i was telling people on the video um
with the personal budgeting i was like
hey if this gets 50
000 views i'll tell you guys exactly how
much i make from
all the income streams because i've got
you know five different businesses and
you know youtube is just the newest
and that's where i'm like i treat for me
i treat youtube and anything i do like a
business like hey
how do i set up systems and processes
and how can i scale this
so that you know i'm not so involved on
it
wow that's incredible you're going to do
well on youtube i already know it
is it because i think it's because of
your professionalism
on youtube just everything is immaculate
and your willingness to learn and
improve
every single episode just the content
you make the background is awesome your
thumbnails are good your
your ti your titles are a little niche
but i think that's going to improve
i mean this is i would be doing the same
thing under 100k subscribers i'd be
going niche and then as you go an
audience you can start making content
whatever you want
so i think you'll be at a hundred
thousand pretty soon yeah
hopefully yeah i'm gonna have to get
some tips from you after this no you
will
a hundred percent uh wow congratulations
that's incredible yeah thank you so so i
mean here's the thing i mean if we look
at that 20 000 a month
it's a lot of money um
but to you you're making enough where
that's that's yeah
you're saving still what 80 of your your
income at least
yeah yeah where else do you invest
besides real estate
honestly not a lot um so i've got some
money in the market
uh i think like 200 000
and i a lot of it's in tesla a lot of
it's
honestly i couldn't even tell you i just
don't really care for stocks that much
um for me most of it's in real estate so
like we have
what do we have like 35 flips going on
right now
so there's a lot of money in flips you
know a lot of my wealths and rentals
i think we have almost 30 rentals um
and then for me actually i use most of
my money
for my businesses so i'm like always
reinvesting into my businesses
because my philosophy is like why invest
in
a stock in someone else's business when
i got my own
i would rather have full control and be
able to affect the
because because they're doing all the
work for you i think for me at least
i've started shifting a lot towards the
stock market
it's just nice just putting my money
away and not having it with
there's a sense of just relief and no
stress
no worries market's going to go up and
down
but it's just as a good store of of of
wealth and money and
even if i make just four percent a year
on that i'm totally fine with that
right it's just no stress it just
declutters your life
it's one less thing to worry about i for
me i
like the stress really i enjoy
starting new things you know having
employees and like
being able to like you know create a
business
that provides value like all i mean your
youtube channel provides
so much value to everyone imagine doing
that
you know on other things as well you
know you could have
all these different businesses that you
you know have such an impact on
yeah and i i really just enjoy the
entrepreneur side of everything
i really do i don't like being passive
yeah uh you know what we got to change
that battery on that yeah i don't know
see for me i was the exact same way
uh because i wanted to really maximize
everything i'm doing but now it's it's
it's i've wanted to
go away from that and just and just it's
the peace of mind
i value so much more now of just not
having to do those things and just
taking a little bit more of a laid-back
approach
without as much responsibility it's been
really nice yeah
i hear you i mean and that's most
people's goal right if you can just
do whatever you want like that's the
dream
so i mean i for me i would just get
bored
if i had nothing to do and no like
em employees and people to like hang out
with it like honestly me going to the
office is like
me going to recess every day because i
see all the people
we're interacting we're making deals
we're doing things
um and then when you see like their
lives impacted by it because
you know i was telling you we got a lot
of employees and a lot of realtors and
so
to know that our company's success is
what
you know makes them provide for their
family and you know you know their wives
you know their kids you know
their spouses like you just can't really
get that
with stocks you know it's just
it's a transaction you know how many
hours a week
would you say you work so i go to the
office
monday through friday uh 10 to five so
35 hours
um i don't work weekends um and really
just those 35 hours i just
try and put in as much as i can to all
the various things i'm doing
so you do everything in 35 hours a week
yeah with weekends off yeah and evenings
yep
that's insane that's a lot so that's a
lot man
30 you said 31 31 31
and to be doing that that is well and
i'll tell you too like
the youtube thing is the one i'm trying
to figure out
because we were talking i was talking to
andre about this
you know he's having trouble because
he's working non-stop to produce
awesome videos and i'm like dude
i can't do that like at the end of the
day i got to figure out how can i
produce
as many videos as possible with you know
as high of quality as possible
in the shortest amount of time that's
literally my goal with youtube's
and so somehow we've scaled to a video
every day
and like it's not that time consuming
so for me i film every monday so all my
guys know that don't talk to me on
monday
and i'm doing it at the office i'm just
gonna film five videos today
i'll film all five pass it off to the
editors
you know i'm done for the week do you
script out your videos
i bullet point them very light scripting
maybe like seven bullet points that i
want to make sure i hit
but i'm pretty good at freestyling most
of them
that's impressive i would i would never
was never able to do that i spent so
long
for me to make those three videos a week
i would say it's probably 50 hours of
work
really there's three videos a week yeah
wow the second channel
is fun the second channel sometimes it's
sometimes you got to get in the mood for
that
because you got to be in that like you
know kind of happy
uppity mood and sometimes i wake up in
the morning and i'm just like i don't
want to
and but but you just do it but yeah the
main channels is the grind that's like
hours
every day of figuring out like what is
going to be the best topic
it's going to be interesting i'm
planning it out and researching the
video then
titles and thumbnails could take hours
and that's what i mean but that's why
you're so successful
you know and i'm kind of taking a
different approach to it
we'll see how it goes but it's like okay
for instance if you have the normal
youtuber who does that
you know i can't compete with that i
just personally don't want to do it
you know how can i still though have a
channel that's successful and to me it's
like
if i can put out a high volume of videos
but there's still
you know good videos even if they're
less researched and less
i mean like i don't i don't have to
research anything like i'm not
researching
what's going on in the stock market i
don't talk about that stuff like that's
not my thing
but all literally everything i talk
about is just my own experiences from
business
and so i'll just be like hey here's the
top three things like i do to find house
flips i don't have to like research it
i'm like boom boom boom here's the three
you know go on to the next thing so
most of them are just no researching at
all so that's the thing
and where are you looking to grow are
you looking to grow in like popularity
on youtube on tick tock
grow your business or grow your income
what's your what's your main focus right
now with
in regards of growth that's a good one
dude
i think you want to grow everywhere
right i mean everyone wants to grow
their business their wealth their
you know social media and influence like
i don't think you'd see anyone who's
like nah
i don't want to grow they wouldn't be
successful if they didn't
um so i i would say i want to grow them
all but what i'll say is like
over the years the priority has always
changed
so when i was growing my house slipping
business i was strictly just
house flipping you know i wasn't worried
about social media
and all this other stuff i'm like how do
i grow this business to be in you know
multi-million dollar business like
it's gonna take all my effort and then
once i grew that and put the right
people in place where
you know they can now run it then i'm
like okay what's next
okay right now it just happens to be a
season where i'm like
let's just try and be the best youtube
and tick-tock
guy that i can you know and i'm still
just
experimenting figuring it out like
trying new thumbnails trying different
titles different topics
um different video links like today i
did a baseball video
totally flop people don't even care i'm
like well you know is that youtube
yeah so i'm like well i guess people
just don't really care that much about
my baseball career
you know they follow me for business and
real estate whatever that's fine
um so i'm just experimenting right now
and even with video frequency i'm going
seven days a week
i think that's probably too much yeah i
wouldn't i
for you like this i would not be doing a
video a day
yeah i'd rather see you put out two
really quality videos like andre
yeah then seven videos uh like this one
a day
yeah and so that's that's where the
tweaking is is like
do i want to keep doing seven a day see
how that goes
or try two a day or two a week sorry and
see how that goes
i would say do do my schedule do three
times a week try that
your thumbnails are pretty good
thumbnails i think are high quality
yeah why i don't give my wife an
allowance
that's a good one wow
wow why didn't why don't you give your
wife an allowance i like that you hit
that like button right
now i just saw that just your habit
that's a habit
you didn't even see it you like it no i
always every almost every video i click
on just you just like
think i like it because you don't even
know you're doing it seriously like that
that was totally unconscious it's weird
i just always hit the like button gosh
so yeah so what so what's the situation
that's with it i don't know what this is
another one
yeah i'm just testing right so i was
like you know what a lot of people ask
me like
what's it like being an entrepreneur
how's your wife handle that how do you
handle
having two kids and doing all that i'm
curious yeah i was like you know what
that sounds like a series let's try it
out and so we've been trying it out for
the last couple of weeks
um and my wife enjoys doing it yeah so
i'm telling you your wife
doesn't work she's she's yeah she's a
stay-at-home mom yeah i mean two kids
two years old that's gonna that's
full-time yeah probably works more than
35 hours
she works more than me for sure for sure
um
but it's like it's another series and it
it's doing pretty good
i just i don't know what direction and
tell me did you know what direction at
50 000 subscribers that you were gonna
take
or you were just still in that
experience no i i had a pretty good
direction on that
okay but i also had a lot of other
channels to look to
right who were doing way better than i
was and so i saw what they were doing
and i'm like okay i see their flaws and
i see
where they're missing the mark and i'm
gonna put my own spin on this i'm gonna
do it in my
way right so i had a direction yeah uh
it actually becomes harder as you grow
because then it's like
who can you start to look to or like
what do you have to look up to
uh for direction now it's like it's
harder because you got to figure it out
on your own yeah now you gotta just no
it's free stuff now it's like
you you like like the tracks have been
laid before you and you just got to
follow the tracks but then you get to a
point
there's no more tracks so you got to
figure out okay now now i'm just
navigating my own now well in the hard
part is once you've
you know took in a path to get there to
go and try and switch it up is scary
right so yeah so with this with your
wife then how
what's what's the allowance thing or
what yeah how does this work
so this video was about um just
how do we manage money in our
relationship and we know a lot of
married couples who
you know they either have uh split bank
accounts
or you know someone gets an allowance or
whatever the case may be
and that that's kind of the thing is
like i don't give my wife an allowance
like she can spend whatever she wants
you know that the title makes it seem
like oh man i'm this big
right yeah i like the title that's why i
clicked on yeah
but but it is i don't give her an
allowance like she can spend whatever
she wants you know
um so yeah that was just about managing
money
this might be too much of the fun has
there ever been a time where she's spent
money
and you've been like i can't believe
like like that would lead to some sort
of like
argument starbucks or something like
that
you know what's funny so when we first
got married right we're really poor
we're young and poor
and she's in college going to be a
teacher which another poor profession
and um i would always get honor because
i'm like you cannot be getting starbucks
you cannot
you know like we're gonna have the
keurig but not even like the k-cup we're
gonna do like the refillable
keurig deal um and so we were super
frugal
and that's why i resonate with a lot of
the things you did because i did the
same exact stuff
i'm just don't do it anymore but like
eventually we started making money and
you know then she got her louis vuitton
bag and other stuff
but it's never like crazy you guys are
on the same wavelength when it comes to
that i'm guessing i'm not gonna get mad
at her for getting a bag
when i have nice stuff too you know what
i'm saying
we got to do the outfit thing okay oh
yeah how much is it yeah let's
walk us through it sure i it looks like
i have a similar shirt to that i don't
want to say that's h
m it is yeah see i have a very similar
shirt
i i had that shirt in the v-neck i got
rid of the v-neck one because it got a
hole
in the armpit uh so now i just have the
normal that's the one i wear all the
time that gray shirt
yeah but not the v-neck okay so h m um
this is um so lulu is expensive
all right that's what 110 no this one's
150.
150. on sale too it's 200. geez
why can i feel man it feels like a zara
jacket that could be like
let me give it that's a 60 jacket from
zara probably
yeah probably i like it all right thank
you jack
um jeans jeans good fitting jeans
yeah what do you think they are how much
do you think they cost hugo boss
no i've never bought anything hugo box
the uh levi's
um my guests the thing with jeans they
could be anywhere from 20 bucks
to like 300 or 500 bucks and they look
exactly
what i've been telling you what do you
think they are um i
i'm going to guess honestly these are 60
jeans they're like 60 dollar jeans
they were like a facebook ad like the
perfect
new york or something gene i can't
remember what they were but they're good
cool
yeah all right that's pretty good yeah
yeah it makes sense yeah no sense gram
same oh yeah so this this shirt again
this is brett oppenheim this shirt was
free every
uh then sweatpants this was a gift this
is a christmas gift sweatpants uh
socks were also brett oppenheim uh i kid
you not and then
underwear is awesome so
basically my entire outfit is from brett
this video was sponsored by bradley
this entire outfit i'm wearing is free
everything the watch
and well not the watch yeah not the
watch but besides the watch
this entire outfit so how much is the
watch it's like 20.
okay so yeah you're you're outdressing
me i've got an apple watch
so that's incredible yeah that's
incredible there we go what about you
jack what about today
the the shirt was a gift yeah the pants
were also
a gift really and uh yeah okay and
that's it
that's right that's literally it yeah
hat was a gift as well
really oh nice wow there we go we're
just getting gifted clothing
what size you wear like i'll get you a
medium
maybe large that's a large yay all right
i'm gonna gift you a bunch of clothes
whoa subscribe to ride
wow make sure you do that right now no
my
no what's funny is my employees like
they know because
i have a very pretty small closet for my
house and so
for me to get a new piece of clothing i
have to get rid of one
that's how it goes same thing with shoes
like if i want to get rid of a shoe i
gotta
or if i want to get a shoe i gotta get
rid of a shoe and so
my employees are all very similar build
and so they get
all my old stuff whether pretty much
like brett oppenheimer yes
jason and i are pretty much the same
size yeah so
usually how it starts is jason will get
something but he'll just not like it
and he never returns it so it goes to
brett brett will wear it for about six
months
brett changes his uh outfit so often and
then he cleans out his entire wardrobe
and then i end up with like 60 and then
eric from my office gets another 40
wow sometimes it's whoever's in the
office at the right time brett will come
in
and it's a free-for-all that that's
exactly what happens at our office too
i just literally will dump the shoes in
the bag of club like guys whoever wants
it wants it
it's smart because i got a whole bunch
of stuff that i gave jack that just i
haven't worn in in a long time
yeah and and for jack it's like whoa
isn't that so crazy is that
this graham shirt yeah plus superhero
now upgrades
for me it's i'm cleaning out but but
that's how i feel when i get clothes
from bread or jason
like it's it's made my day what about
like have you got expensive clothes like
suits and stuff
i have one suit that i bought um
probably over 10 years ago
1200 bucks and tailored yeah that's the
same jacket i wear to this day
uh the pants have a hole in them
unfortunately but that's okay
besides that i don't really know i don't
really i never bought anything
more than like 100 maybe 200 bucks other
than that what about you
what's your most expensive article of
clothing i actually don't like have
expensive clothing
you know like i buy a lot of you know
not expensive but like good you know i
don't have a
thousand dollar suit i don't even think
i have a clothing over
200 like this might be it
so i'm i'm more about buying just i like
to just switch my style i know my style
switches all the time so it's like
i'm not gonna buy a two thousand dollar
suit so where do you waste your money
then
where do you spend your wife likes
louis vuitton she does i like food yeah
um
i sp i don't even spend a lot on shoes i
buy a lot of shoes but they're like
50 to 80 bucks it's not like i'm a
sneaker head buying
yeah jordan's this yeah this would have
been the perfect segue we got a sponsor
coming up
we can't plug the sponsor here this
would have been the perfect segue for
this sponsor
we're not going to mention it here but
this time
this actually this episode might go up
in november really and if it does
i could insert okay we'll see
there you go um what do you think about
frugality
in general and graham's take on
frugality do you think he takes it too
extreme or do you think that it makes
sense
considering like overall like priorities
and you could be harsh here
yeah you could be you could you could
you could tell the truth you're in a
safe spot with
what what you say on the podcast does
not get taken personally
you never be invited back
um you know
i like i said i was just like you as
terms of frugality
when i was really broke and then it just
changed once
i started making money lifestyle
inflation
yeah for sure for sure but even still
like you said it's like
i was never one of those guys that's
like okay i'm gonna go buy bentley now
or whatever like i could but that's not
me like
it's still a waste i've i've been
looking at like
ap watches and stuff and i'm like man i
really that would be tight
but i could see you with a nice
stainless steel royal oak
yeah i want an offshore royal oak
offshore but i'm like
it's just not like i can't justify it so
i still have those
in terms of like other stuff i think you
could justify it because it's not going
to go down in value you get a good deal
on a stainless steel watch
that's going to keep its value that's
that's that's your savings account right
there that's the way i would see it
well i might get one then but you know i
i've kind of gotten
bigger with it but for you it's like
you just gotta do what makes you happy
like if being frugal makes you happy
like
no one should force themselves to spend
which is obviously where you're
just like you enjoy waiting for sushi at
the end of the week if you got sushi
every day you'd be like i don't enjoy
this anymore yeah
you know i understand that um
and it it's just like i want to see what
happens with you
once you achieve like just crazy wealth
because you're gonna get there so it's
like at what point is graham gonna be
like
yeah you know doing the the iced coffees
just doesn't make sense anymore when is
that gonna
never it's never gonna not make sense
because i'd like i prefer this coffee
over starbucks
what when will you start spending
i don't even know what you'd spend more
money on how would you spend more
there's really not much that i want the
only things that i feel like i really
want
is a uh a reef tank that that's just
something it's more of a logistical
thing i was gonna put a reef tank here
okay but if i'm spending
uh time in vegas put it moving there i
wanna put it there so reef tank is
something i
absolutely want uh the piano is
something i'm gonna get
i got the drum set this year okay um i
think
maybe you know what like now it's things
to save time
i would say is that is like a a driver
i think it would be really nice i i paid
jack once to drive me to
uh to ventura yeah one night and i got
editing done i got an hour and a half of
editing done in the car
that's a running joke at my company too
it's like who's gonna
send the driver yeah so i would say
probably that's the only thing that i
could think of that would really improve
the quality
of my life is just not having to drive
but that's not like a
unnecessary exp that's a business right
like you're trying to gain time like
that's smart
but like spending for no reason like
would you ever
well you probably don't travel enough
but would you ever buy a jet no
well you know what i mean if i had
unlimited money
yeah like and and just there there are
so many zeros in a bank account i would
for the purpose of saving time right so
you're down to spend the same time
yes at this point you get a personal
chef all those things
probably yeah yeah all those things they
save time right
what about i guess then it just comes
down to material items
like at the end of the day is there the
reef tank the reef tank
tank i would love a rolex daytona but
but part of me purposely just doesn't
want to buy those things
yeah because i i like looking forward to
them right i like the fact that like
i could go on ebay every now and then
and look through it look for a deal
and just and just like wish and be like
oh one day i want to get the rolex
daytona how do you trick yourself though
because like
you can get it how do you trick yourself
because it's like one just a silly
purchase like i don't need one right now
right i like i like having that to look
forward to
so i i keep it there and and
unfortunately
those prices have gone up so i've lost a
lot of money
no just so i started looking at the
rolex it's a zenith rolex daytona yeah i
started looking at this watch back in
like 2012
and wondering why is this watch the same
price as the normal daytonas and this is
2012. and back then this this watch and
a stainless steel was maybe like
nine to ten thousand dollars and i was
like oh i can't afford it i was throwing
everything into real estate
and then the prices started going up on
them and then they're like 15. i'm like
wait a second now it's 15 now it's too
expensive
um but i really wanted that watch now
they're like 40 to 50 grand
sometimes even more if you get the
watches with box and papers because
people realize like the zenith rolex
daytona was really rare it was only
made for a few years and it's the same
movement in this watch and that's why i
want it because it plays off of
the whole zenith thing so i've lost a
lot of money
i could have forexed my money on that
well you know what's funny is
i've never cared about watches or
cars or anything you know um
i didn't even start getting curious
about watches until youtube because
for whatever reason the algorithm keeps
showing me them
and then like i was hanging out with a
couple of people and they were talking
about
rolexes and ap i'm like i didn't even
know what an ap was until six months ago
not even lying and i heard you say on a
video before patek
i'm like i don't even know what a patek
is i had no idea and then i start
researching them i'm like okay like
i want one like i want an ap i've
narrowed it down this is what i want
and it's just funny how that works it's
just like
i never had a desire to get one i i
yeah i would recommend you get one
because i feel like it's one of those
things that once you
once you buy a watch like that you
understand just the art behind it and
the history behind the manufacturer
and there are those people who just get
the watches to flex
right and those are the dudes with the
gold and everything who blows and
they're you know
and but but there's there's an art and a
sophistication behind these really great
watches and they hold their value and
some of them go up in value
and it's just really neat to get behind
i feel like at some point i get there
with art
too right and just the history behind it
is it and just the significance of
certain pieces i think is really unique
yeah um so that like i should i should
get a dinosaur skull one day like some
real like some t
like some actual what's in your student
don't you have like some dinosaurs
that's a replica
oh if that were real i mean that would
be like 700 grand
yeah but you will probably spend 700
grand at some point
is what you're saying okay so yeah so
here that i do weird stuff like that
like i will
pinch pennies and then i would do
something like that like spend like 300
grand in a dinosaur school
that's what i'm getting everything until
then i'd be like no i'm not going to pay
extra that's an extra 10 cents i'm not
going to do that that's what i'm getting
at because
we know that it makes no sense at all
that does make sense because i don't
want to overspend it's not like
it makes complete sense yeah it does
because like if you're saving a dollar
but you're gonna go spend 300
000. like what does it matter because
you all those starbucks are not going to
be
because the value it's like why waste
money i i always
go back to the days where i remember
what it was like
uh i worked this just brief job at this
place called gold line international
like right at the time i was graduating
high school before i got my license
i remember making like eight dollars an
hour it was like eight to ten an hour i
can't remember
and how hard i had to work to make 10
bucks an hour
and so i still see things as though i'm
making ten dollars an hour and i think
like
that coffee is half hours of the work
for a lot of people that's that's stupid
that's a waste of money
so i still respect money in the same way
as back then like
i remember 20 bucks how far you could
make 20 go
so like for little things like that fine
it's harder to conceptualize like what's
a 200 000
piece of art right that's so inte
i don't know that there are many people
like you on that aspect like i think
you're very unique in that you know
you see the value of something so
expensive like that an
art or a watch or you know stuff that's
you know not a
necessity right and you know this other
stuff it's like
i've just it's so deep in your dna that
it'll never change
yeah but but those things i feel like
once you once you consume them they're
gone
like the starbucks right that's gone as
soon as they drink it close
or wear it for a few months let's say a
year or two the shelf life of that is
pretty
small a piece of art is gonna stay
forever the value is there forever
with a watch that's an heirloom piece
that you could pass down if you need the
money instead
it's really it's just transferring my
money from like cash
to now all of a sudden it's this piece
of art yeah all the money's still there
so i'm not losing anything in that
transaction versus a starbucks
or an overpriced dinner or like a pair
of uh
like sneakers right that's gone so
that's the way i see it i get a really
good book for you to read
it's called die with zero have you ever
heard of it no
um it's essentially talking about how
you know the goal in life essentially
should be to die with zero and
it doesn't mean like go spend all your
money because you don't know when you're
gonna die right yeah
but it comes down to like well wouldn't
it be better let's let's
let's just say your dream was to give
away a lot of money wouldn't it be
better to give away that money while
you're alive
but you don't but you but you don't know
when no you don't but also you'd want to
pass them down to family right and take
care of your family and your friends
but then you don't know when you're i
mean if we had a timeline saying like
listen like
20 years from now no i don't know i
don't want to jinx it
but let's just say you're 80 years old
and they're like okay
you're going to pass away this age right
then maybe it's like okay let's let's
have some fun here
right you want to enjoy that when you're
younger well well this is the point of
die with zeros like
okay in the end it would be better to
give it away
while you're alive so you could see your
family enjoy it right
instead of you're dead you have no idea
what happens okay with that
but like while you're young his theory
is you should spend more on experiences
which is what i was going to get into
what's your take on
vacations experiences and that stuff
because he says when you have
experiences when you're younger
you get to hold on to those experiences
your whole life but when you have when
you're older
you're in worse shape you don't get to
keep the experience
long because it's later in life so like
you should invest in experiences
while you're young yeah i don't know i
enjoy working so much though
like it has not i mean it's crossed my
mind to go on vacations every now but i
enjoy working at this
at this juncture right now i work i
think is uh takes a bit of a priority
and i think in the future it's good
that's gonna change at some point right
it's fascinating uh i was talking with
my grandpa and he's getting older
and he says that the last line
in the great gatsby can sum up like your
final years in life or whatever pretty
well
and it's something along the lines of
like um and we move on like votes
against the current yada yada something
being born ceaselessly into the past or
something
and he says like when you're older all
you really have
in the end are your memories right so
why would you want to use those years
where all you can
really do or all you do is reflect back
on life why would you want to have all
of those things
when you wouldn't even be able to use
them and all you can think back on is
all the times when you were younger and
you were taking advantage of all of
those
right all of your well that's the whole
point of the book is like
you know when you're young you're you're
at your healthiest you're enjoying like
for me
i look back in my 20s and i see when i
was 21 playing baseball for no money
grinding it out on the bus i loved it
you know
and i look back on all the places i
traveled um
over the country and it's like you
couldn't take those memories away from
me
you know and i wasn't making any money
doing it
you know i definitely delayed my wealth
you know
immensely because of that you know you
go play minor league baseball for eight
years
getting nothing it's like okay you're
not really working towards your future
doing that you're just enjoying
the process and i i'll trade that for
anything and now it's like okay
i experienced that my 20s were awesome
playing baseball
now it's like all right my 30s let's
spend it really building
an empire essentially so i took the
opposite approach i took my 20s
right build the empire in your 20s and
then early 30s probably mid-30s and then
and then after that but you're going to
keep building that's where the thing is
though at some point you're going to
decide
do i stop building and start enjoying or
do i just continue to build the empire
i have a feeling it's going to i have a
feeling at some point it's going gonna
shift
yeah at some point i don't know exactly
when but i've always taken it that like
your early years of the time where you
really just put your head down
you work away and that gives you so many
options in the future like i'd rather
have like a guaranteed 35 you could do
whatever right
then start at 30 right start at like 28
and then well that's the con that's the
wisdom we always hear from
you know the big entrepreneurs and stuff
is like grind while your 20s and
get ahead and you know you'd be set up
on your 30s
and this book kind of shifts that but
here's the thing too
you have the energy and the stamina in
your 20s to pull those 12-hour days
right every single day right i think
it's
harder to do that as you get older with
more responsibilities and with a family
right like putting in those 12-hour days
now
for you would be very difficult with a
wife and kid i mean i know you could do
it i'm sure you could do it
but it wouldn't be as easy as let's say
10 years ago 100
you're absolutely right so i feel like
from a career perspective you get that
competitive advantage and i feel like
fewer people are doing it when you're
younger yeah because most people and
maybe not most but i feel like a lot of
people take that approach that i have my
entire life ahead of me let me at least
just
do my things now and then by 30 i could
get serious
yeah so i know there's pros and cons and
here's the thing i think
whatever uh place people take that's
what they recommend so everyone who's
like i
lived it up in my 20s i partied yeah
that's the best
and then everyone who didn't do that
you're like no no i worked away that's
the best
yeah i don't use any convincing either
either way that makes sense
that people would just act on what they
inherently desire
yeah what i mean like your inherent
desires are different than yours right
you probably naturally just fall into
that chance right well and for me though
i was working really hard towards my
goal like i wasn't out partying doing
stuff like i was like strictly
practice work out eat right do all the
things work i work way harder in my 20s
than i do now
seriously um it's just it's like
i don't think at some point you got to
value the experiences of life
over the material things the investments
because like
we can buy the the investment and the
material thing and
even if we own it forever like art or a
watch versus
clothes which have a lifespan it's like
that memory is worth something
and the longer you have that memory you
know earlier in life
the more valuable it is because you get
to hold it longer i have a terrible
memory that's
the problem i forget things every day
bleeds by to the next and i swear like
maybe i'll have
some conversations like and two days ago
i'm like wait what day was that
was that like last week what was this
again i think i forgot
i'll remember anything like with the s p
500 like i'll all remember what nancy
pelosi
said but like every day like i don't i
don't remember
like more than like three days ago
seriously it's really bad but i think
that's like
when you work from home every day and
you're just yeah
it is it becomes a blur yeah
[Laughter]
anyway oh we should probably rap wrap up
we got a good episode
yeah is there anything else that you'd
just like to end off saying any advice
any word i mean we covered a lot
we covered life investing
uh businesses we're getting better at
the podcast you're getting us
at uh so far i would say our best
because in the beginning we were a
little bit too structured
we we we were good but we had a
structure we had an outline and now
we're figuring this out 20 episodes in
yeah of like how to do these and what to
talk about yeah and i've noticed
going in without a plan and just having
a natural conversation
seems to be what most people enjoy i
think so so give give us your take on
this and if you've made it this far let
us know down in the comments
one thing that i realized and i brought
up to graham on one of our runs
is that if we don't come in with some
sort of outline because for the first
like 20 or so episodes
i'll prepare two page long outlines for
every single podcast and i would make
sure that we would hit every single one
of those talking points
and it became kind of an issue because
if i make all of these bullet points
that we have to hit
that's our cap on how entertaining or
exciting it can be
because that's it's exactly where we're
leveled off
whereas i see other podcasts like joe
rogan and they kind of just
go in with it and then wherever the
conversation goes they just keep going
there
and i think like conversation naturally
will lead to the most exciting
like just chat you know like we will
naturally just
gravitate towards the most exciting
thing because that's what we want to
talk about rather than your hair at
hearing
yeah your hair and your wife's allowance
it restricts us when we have to adhere
to these bullet points so let us know
what you guys think about that
uh thank you for coming on yes so much
we really appreciate it it was a great
you weren't recording
getting it
got him gotcha
hey but that was a great speech you
crushed it and everyone will hear it
thanks yeah i always try to mess with
jack every now and then
record all the time all the time i try i
try
you're like listening to yourself speak
to yeah i literally i checked it like
i've checked it like 10 times too yeah
during this episode
usually like once or twice a week i'll
try to throw a curveball and he doesn't
keep him on his testosterone it feels
like when i fall off a curb or whatever
and you get like that
jolt in your heart i have to redo that
that two minutes
yeah the filibuster gosh
well um on a final note how was your
coffee
it was delicious you know i've been um
waiting for this day
ever since i found out it was a you know
graham specialty and it lived up to it
good i'm glad yeah i couldn't finish
mine it's late
i want to be up all night so i gotta i
gotta
keep it keep it to a minimum so cool
well thank you guys so much for watching
i really appreciate it i'll link to all
your information down below in the
description let's get you to a hundred
thousand subscribers
yeah and with the iced coffee out let's
get this to a hundred thousand
subscribers too
yeah we could do it if you're watching
interesting if everybody watching this
just subscribed
we'd get there like almost overnight 200
000 yeah because yeah some of those
episodes did over a hundred thousand
i know but we gotta tell them to
subscribe in the beginning
you gotta tell them to subscribe yeah
but if they're watching the end fifty
percent watch to the end
even the fifty thousand people so if you
watch this video and you're not
subscribed i don't
that's tough yeah just again just
comment down below and let me know why
you're not subscribed
the only excusable reason is that you
don't have an account and you're not
logged in
that's it make an account that's it and
subscribe thank you so much for doing
that
uh we'll put our instagrams down there
if you guys want three
free stocks from weeble you can get that
down below in the description
and uh yeah thank you thank you so much
for watching the mentorship group this
this episode is sponsored by the
mentorship group so if you want to join
the link to that is down below in the
description we meet every single sunday
morning and thursday night
uh one of the zoom call so if you just
want to talk do whatever jack's there
i'm there
want to talk to us ask us questions it's
really fun so link
is uh down below in the description so
thank you so much for watching and until
next time
until next time go perfect
excuse me right here so this would be do
you want to introduce us on this
we usually have the guests introducing
okay what what's the intro supposed to
be like
welcome to the 24th ever episode of the
iced coffee hour
and then you just say i mean should we
say how much we've made because we're
doing this
back to i mean we need it you could just
say
yeah we should yeah yeah yeah um just
say we've made
ten thousand it's about ten thousand
five hundred ten thousand five hundred
ten thousand five hundred dollars in the
podcast thus far okay so
this is the 24th ever ever episode of
the iced coffee hour we've made a proc
if you mess up it doesn't matter we've
made approximately 10 500
should i say we or you guys it doesn't
matter it's a wii okay yeah
say we because it's a it's a group
effort here all right sounds good i just
wait one sec
go so
what's good so just hey we're it's the
24th uh welcome to the 24th ever
yeah here we go welcome to the 24th ever
episode
of the ice coffee podcast our
iced coffee hour podcast we should just
call it the iced coffee podcast
yeah we should that's what everyone just
ends up saying really you think so the
iced coffee i call it the iced coffee
hour
but what do you think what do you think
i think the iced coffee podcast is good
just coffee podcast i don't want to make
it seem like
it's uh all about iced coffee though
that's true
all right anyway again all right
here we go welcome to the 24th ever
episode of the ice coffee
hour podcast we've approximately made
ten thousand dollars
wait what ten thousand five hundred
thousand okay all right here we go
all right so um hold on how do how do we
avril
lavigne dude i don't think
really sounds